and you will spend
the first 150 days of your sentence in
the cook county jail i am innocent and i
am not suicidal man
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal that's jessie smallett's
emotional statement in court after being
sentenced to 150 days in jail in 30
months of felony probation jesse's
attorney said they plan to appeal the
sentencing and if anything happens to me
when i go in there i did not do it to
myself and you must all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal in december the actor
was found guilty on five counts of
disorderly conduct for his role in lying
to law enforcement about a staged attack
against himself a massive investigation
into costing the city and his residents
well over 100 thousand dollars on
thursday judge james lynn listens to
statements from both prosecution and
defense teams as well as character
witnesses speaking on jesse's behalf
i felt compelled to come and tell you
that the jesse i know and love does not
match up with the media's
betrayal of him that's jesse's 92 year
old grandmother taking the stand
i ask you the judge not to send him to
prison if you do send me along with him
okay after sentencing jesse shared
another impassioned statement
i am not suicidal
i am not suicidal and i am innocent i
could have said that i was guilty a long
time ago the judge also ordered jesse to
pay a
and twenty thousand dollars in
restitution along with a twenty five
thousand dollar fine at the onset of
trial jesse pleaded not guilty and later
testified in his defense outside the
courthouse jesse sibling spoke out
against the sentencing first of all i
want to say my brother is innocent my
brother jesse is innocent this should
not be a controversial statement because
it is the absolute truth
he was attacked
and he is now going to jail for being
attacked and here is where jesse has
star power on his side leading up to his
sentencing hearing jesse had a high
profile ally in his corner samuel l
jackson et obtained a letter sent to
judge lynn written by the marvel star
and his wife latonya richardson jackson
natalia and i you know give service
in every way we possibly can dated
february 24th the letter cites jesse's
previous humanitarian work and pleads
for leniency as the judge considered
jesse's sentencing they asked quote
please find an alternative to
incarceration for jesse smallett the
couple also say they know his family
quote intimately revealing they lived
down the street from jesse when he was a
baby they added quote please save this
young man and allow him to be of service
jesse smallett is worth the risk in
investment their heartfelt message was
read aloud during thursday's hearing
along with statements from alfree
woodard and reverend jesse jackson